das könnte die entwicklung der
quantencomputer enorm voran treiben die
rede ist vom mechanismen die eine
fehleranalyse in quantencomputern
erstmals möglich machen gleich zwei
studien zur fehlerkorrektur in
quantencomputern wurden jetzt
vorgestellt fehler können hier einfach
weg gebiet werden klicks umsatz im
future geht es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
ist das der durchbruch für
quantencomputer eine neue
quantentechnologie könnte nicht nur
unsere wirtschaft sondern auch unsere
gesellschaft verändern schon jetzt gibt
es viele technische anwendungen der
quantenphysik die für unseren alltag
entscheiden sind konnten computer gelten
als das große ding der zukunft sie sind
nämlich in der lage aufgaben nicht nur
schneller sondern auch deutlich
effizienter zu lösen als herkömmliche
computer und so können kranken computer
viele komplexe probleme der menschheit
lösen konkret sind anwendungen in
zahlreichen verschiedenen bereichen
denkbar in der medikamentenforschung für
berechnung in der logistik der
finanzwirtschaft bei künstlicher
intelligenz oder datensicherheit all das
würde unglaublich viel schneller und
besser berechnet werden können ein
abhörsicheres kanten internet über das
gespeicherte informationen über große
entfernungen ausgetauscht werden könnte
sogar eine neue ära der kommunikation
einleiten die große herausforderung das
system muss quasi komplett von der
außenwelt abgeschirmt werden um
zuverlässig zu sein bis also fand ein
computer großflächig zum einsatz kommt
wird es möglicherweise noch einige jahre
dauern einen durchbruch wählen nun ein
forschungsteam aus china und österreich
erreicht haben konkret geht es um die
fehleranalyse bei optischen
quantencomputers ein echt großes ding
denn quantencomputer reagieren sehr
empfindlich auf äußere einflüsse immer
wieder können sich fehler einschleichen
und diese können bislang nicht so
einfach korrigiert werden wie in
herkömmlichen computern die neue
technologie basiert auf der ferne
übertragung von quanteninformation also
auf der teleportation dem beamen der
quantenverschränkung die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus china und österreich bezeichnet ihre
forschung als regelrechten durchbruch
was genau ist da dran und wie
funktioniert der neue mechanismus für
fehlerkorrektur in optischen
quantencomputers die spannende antworten
auf all diese fragen und noch viel mehr
gibt es jetzt hier bei konstanz im
future fanden computer rechnen anders
als klassische computer nicht mit bits
die den wert 1 oder 0 annehmen also an
oder aus sind strom leiten oder eben
nicht quantencomputer basieren auf den
sogenannten cubes die beide werte
gleichzeitig annehmen können und so
viele mögliche lösungen zur selben zeit
durch rechnen können oder anders gesagt
in einem klassischen computer handelt es
sich bei der kleinsten recheneinheit um
bits in einem kanten physikalischen
system übernehmen beispielsweise ionen
also quantenbits oder kurz kibiz diese
aufgabe dahinter steckt das phänomen der
verschränkung und diese erlaubt es den
zustand von teilchen wie atome ionen
oder photonen zu koppeln ganz egal wie
weit diese voneinander entfernt sind und
sobald sich der zustand des einen
teilchens ändert gibt es auch beim
verschenken partner teilchen einen
zustand wechsel und genau das ist die
basis für viele super praktische
anwendung der quantenphysik und davon
ist der kranken computer nur eine doch
lasst auch auch quantencomputer sind
noch sehr fehlerbehafteten sie rechnen
zum teil eine menge falsch fehler können
sich unter anderem dann einschleichen
wenn ein quantenbit qubit ungewollt
seinen zustand ändert in einem
klassischen computer können solche
fehler korrigiert werden vergleichen
kann man das mit dem unerwünschten
schalten eines britz von null auf eins
oder eben andersherum ein bit kann
mehrfach kopiert werden um solche fehler
in einem gewöhnlichen computer zu
koordinieren denn die meisten complete
behalten dann den richtigen wert sogar
dann wenn sich einzelne fehler
einschleichen in der quantenwelt ist das
ganz anders den quanteninformation
lassen sich nicht kopieren dazu sagt der
experimentalphysiker rainer blatt wenn
wir in der zukunft wirklich nutzbare
quantencomputer erreichen wollen
brauchen wir mehr kubitz mehr
operationen und zuverlässige operationen
quantencomputer basieren also auf den
vorteilen die karten physikalische
phänomene wie überlagerung also dass sie
beide zustände 0 und 1 annehmen können
und verschränkung mit sich bringen auf
der anderen seite sind diese auch enorm
anfällig nicht nur umwelteinflüsse
sondern auch störungen können zu fehlern
in den berechnungen führen und so wollen
fachleute methoden entwickeln mit denen
sich verifizieren lässt ob ein quanten
chip eine komplexe berechnung präzise
ausgeführt hat oder eben nicht die
österreichische wissenschaftlerin chiara
garantie fordert dass man mit einer
solchen methode das ergebnis einer
berechnung überprüfen können muss ohne
dass die richtige antwort bekannt ist
eine aktuelle studie zu genau diese
herausforderung kommt von einem
internationalen forschungsteam aus
singapur österreich und großbritannien
dazu der physiker martin ringmauer wir
lassen mehrere kanten computer zufällig
aussehende berechnungen durchführen
obwohl die ergebnisse jedes einzelnen
kranken computers zufällig sind müssen
sie wegen der versteckten verbindung in
bestimmten aspekten immer übereinstimmen
eine versteckte verbindung zwischen
diesen berechnungen also macht eine
fehleranalyse möglich stimmen die
berechnungen der verschiedenen
quantencomputer also in dieser
versteckten verbindung über ein sind
sich also die beiden geräte einigt ist
dass ausgerechnet ergebnis also das
richtige ein großer vorteil dieser
analyse nicht das gesamte ergebnis muss
ausgelesen werden und das spart enorm
viel zeit ein weiterer vorteil laut des
forschungsteams auch quantencomputer
beliebiger hardware können gegeneinander
getestet werden die analyse der
aktuellen studie wurde an verschiedenen
quantencomputer getestet die auf
unterschiedlichen technologischen
plattformen basieren in diesem
zusammenhang ist einem weiteren
internationalen forschungsteam ein
riesiger erfolg gelungen sie haben einen
mechanismus entwickelt mit dem die
fehlerkorrektur in optischen
quantencomputer möglich wird diese neue
technologie basiert auch der fern
übertragung von quanteninformation
teleportation oder beamen von
informationen die beteiligten fachleute
bezeichnen ihre entwicklung selbst als
zitat durchbruch das phänomen des bebens
kennt man aus der science fiction serie
star trek bezogen auf die kanten
teleportation bedeutet das dass eine
info die angewandten objekt trägt auf
ein anderes kannten objekt übertragen
wird und zwar über beliebige distanzen
neue physikalische kubitz werden zu
einem virtuellen cupid zusammengefasst
bei dieser idee diese einheit wird in
der fachsprache dann als zitat logische
stupid bezeichnet und genau dieses
system teleportiert dann die
informationen eines einzelnen kubitz
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam so
können wir erkennen ob sich ein fehler
am cupid ereignet hat ohne dessen
zustand zu stört aktiv korrigieren
können wir einen fehler noch nicht das
ist der nächste schritt dennoch ein
riesiger fortschritt denn so werden die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
in die lage versetzt jene ergebnisse zu
verwerfen bei dem die messung an zeigt
dass ein fehler vorliegt konkret basiert
dieser neu entwickelte fehlerkorrektur
mechanismus auf einem neuen cupid system
aus drei photonen waren diese werden in
komplizierte verschränkung zustände
gebracht pro foto gibt es also drei
cupid die die physikerinnen und physiker
unabhängig voneinander manipulieren
können sprich pro photonen werden drei
kanten eigenschaften wie zum beispiel
drehimpuls oder polarisation benutzt
zudem gibt es ein foto das die
informationen trägt die gegen fehler
gesichert werden soll zwei photonen
werden für die kontrolle des systems und
den teleportation prozess ansicht
benötigt die beteiligten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
betonen dass ihre neue technologie eine
signifikant erhöhte qualität zur folge
hat demnach werde die zitat qualität der
cubes signifikant erhöht nach ansicht
des forschungsteams ein entscheidender
schritt um fanden computer weniger
anfällig für fehler zu machen der neu
entwickelte fehler korrekturmechanismus
eignet sich besonders für optische
fanden computer es geht ja um photonen
und kann nach angaben des
internationalen forschungsteams aber auf
allen physikalischen plattformen
eingesetzt werden mit den
quantencomputer realisiert werden
möglichst fehlerfreies rechne ist also
eines der großen ziele an denen
forschende weltweit forschen die
fehlerquote bei googles experiment vor
zwei jahren 2009/10 lag bei 0,5 prozent
ein forschungsteam von google und der
nasa hat damals die überlegenheit von
quantencomputern gegenüber den
schnellsten klassischen computer
nachgewiesen allerdings für eine sehr
spezielle berechnung der kranken
prozessor von google brauchte für die
berechnung einer aufgabe 2 100 sekunden
die ein klassischer computer also ein
supercomputer etwa 10.000 jahre benötigt
hätte damit war die sogenannte quanten
überlegenheit gelungen hier also die
nächste herausforderung dazu der
physiker rainer blatt wir brauchen
verfahren zur verifikation und
validierung die zeigen dass ein
quantenrechner tatsächlich mehr kann als
ein klassischer rechner und hier gibt es
alle infos über die kanten überlegenheit
unbedingt anklicken sensationeller
meilenstein google hat quanten
überlegenheit erreicht das sind wirklich
unglaubliche fortschritte die im moment
auf dem sektor gemacht werden also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran